foreign
[Music]
it is May 2023 and the top three rated
games of this year so far are actually a
decade old
well
sort of
two of our remakes and one of them is a
remastered
so hold on are we running out of ideas
at face value I think it was totally
appropriate to raise an eyebrow
something like that there's plenty of
new games new experiences coming out
this year and yet the ones that are
getting the most attention the top rated
ones are remix I can see why that would
be misconstrued as a negative thing but
I don't entirely see it that way in fact
I think if you look a little closer not
only is it a good thing but I think it
might be one of the only ways right now
to uphold these games Legacy
let's get into it first let's talk about
this whole remake remaster thing and
thankfully these three games paint a
near perfect image of the multi-faceted
even confusing topic because really what
we have here is a remake A remaster and
a reimagining dead space is the Remake
Metroid Prime is the remaster and
Resident Evil 4 is the reimagining the
Remake Dead Space is a to z the same
Journey as the original but Liberties
have been taken Beyond that's extremely
gory albeit beautiful Graphics dialogue
has been completely Rewritten Isaac now
actually speaks weapons are now
introduced naturally in the game's
progression and some side quests have
been tossed in for some extra padding
it's quite a bit a lot of it is quality
of life but if you've played the
original like me even recently you'll
realize that game not only is still very
playable but effectively scary the thing
is this remake is more than just pretty
graphics and writing
it's accessibility things like content
warnings prior to disturbing scenes and
the option to just hide them all
together as well as a plethora of
control Visual and auditory options to
cater to different accessibility
requirements compare that with the
original where these options were
virtually non-existent now while the
Journey of the games are virtually the
same what this remake does is better
contextualize it for the expectations of
players today and make it accessible for
people who literally could not play it
before now let's talk about Metroid
Prime which is the remaster it is beat
for beat the same game with no
additional content in game or changes to
its pacing but it's been completely
overhauled graphically and has a totally
reworked control scheme while still
retaining other control schemes in line
with this original GameCube release or
even motion controls seen on the Wii now
calling this a mere facelift or Port is
a disservice in fact I'm even having
trouble decipher what makes this
different from Blue Points remake of
Shadow of the Colossus they even made
new concept art to re-envision The
Originals they remade them so wouldn't
that make this a remake
and lastly the reimagining residential 4
remake is ultimately an experience all
its own it doesn't stand on the
shoulders of the original but instead
stands alongside it it's in conversation
with the original acknowledges those
players while completely subverting them
entirely and in the process creating a
new experience for players with no
context of the original to say it as
plainly as possible that game kicks so
much ass so the problem becomes that
lumping these three games into the
Remake remaster category just feels
inaccurate because they're all so damn
good but they're damn good for their own
distinct reasons reasons in which I
don't think they replace their Originals
they just now live in a different
context I'd still recommend playing The
Originals of these games because they
paint a different view of what gaming
was like in their respective Years also
I just have to emphasize the whole
playable accessibility thing there's now
way more options for people to actually
be able to play these
and that's great the thing is that still
doesn't quite clear up the whole what is
a remaster thing but there is one other
game that came out this year that I
think makes a pretty compelling case for
it
[Music]
golden Knight got a re-release for Xbox
and switch two distinctly different
approaches to preserving an experience
Xboxes is an emulated version of the
game with alterations to enhance its
resolution but most prominently its
control scheme to make it more familiar
in a modern era the switches is also
emulated with upscaled visuals and a
frame rate at a semi-consistent 30
frames per second but the twist is that
it retains its original control scheme
which is absolutely
mind-boggingly archaic for new audiences
like you shoot with this
you and you move with that but then
you're strafe with this analog stick
it's the same
oh wait that's in two
Jesus Christ of these two versions I'd
say that the switch is actually closer
to preserving the original experience
and that it refused to change the goofy
control scheme but contrary to that
point it's also that only one of the two
versions that has online multiplayer
which would mean that the Xbox actually
has more of an authentic couch
multiplayer experience than the switch
I don't know all that in mind I think
GoldenEye is actually the true form of a
remaster it retained the exact same
Graphics look sound effects soundtrack
Etc but has been up rest with a more
consistent frame rate and some quality
of life control options
in one of the cases
GoldenEye is also the Curious Case of a
game that has been remade slashed
reimagined in 2010 for the Wii in a
weird way its remake is more comparable
to the Resident Evil 4 remake in that it
tried to do something new opposed to
making something one-to-one and try to
reimagine it for a 2010 era except it
didn't really work out the same way as
the Resident Evil 4 remake and they also
replaced Pierce prawns and with Daniel
Craig so
also total sidebar but I just want to
remind everyone that goal and I got a
sequel in 2004 called GoldenEye rogue
agent where like the agent literally had
a gold high
it's a lot to make sense of and can make
for some pretty confusing messages
but I think this this whole discussion
around remasters remakes or reimaginings
all aligned with a broader conversation
preservation the hard truth is that
video games have an expiration date as
the years go on and generations of
Gamers grow up either trying to hold on
to or experience games from the past it
just becomes more and more obvious that
this is a medium that is constantly at
odds with the sands of time as long as
technology grows and becomes more and
more powerful with more pixels and
teraflops and triangles Whatever video
games by their very nature exist in a
very specific context of time when they
were made what they were made with and
who they were made for now there are
some things that have plateaued like the
standard of what makes a good controller
which basically started and ended with
this guy over 20 years ago but there is
the case of something like this
controller from Sega where I guess they
didn't quite catch on to the whole
second analog stick but
kind of leads into
the neutronum make
put trying to play older games is just
incredibly unapproachable for the common
consumer because either one is an
expensive hobby that starkly Narrows the
accessibility of those games to people
with Deep Pockets or two you have to be
Savvy enough to emulate older games
using rather dubious methods and that's
kind of when it clicked for me remakes
and remasters and reimaginings are a way
in which a game's Legacy can actually
live on I never finished Metroid Prime
as a kid so this remaster was my chance
to do that and you know what I can't
tell I'm playing a 20 year old game
until I switch back to its classic
controls and whoo boy yeah however I'm
extremely grateful that the option is
even there remakes and remasters are a
way to renew these experiences and if
Done Right cement why they're important
and maybe even lend as a reminder of
Timeless game design to inspire new
games to come
[Music]
it's not going away as there are still
remakes on the horizon Max Payne One and
Two Silent Hill 2 alone in the dark and
that isn't to mention the prospect of
what else could be on the horizon what
about the rest of the Metroid Prime
series Dead Space 2 Resident Evil 5. I
am always an advocate for new and weird
experiences trust me and there has been
plenty of them this year already play
the game wanted dead I loved it but I
suspect by the end of this generation it
will probably be lost to the past it
just so happens that the game is making
the biggest splash this year are ones
from over a decade ago but I think it's
a necessary step to celebrate this
medium that otherwise may not actually
stand the test of time
but that's just my perspective
let me know what you think
[Music]
hey before you go just want to say thank
you for watching this and if you dug it
well I got news for you pal because
there's a whole bunch more coming over
these next few weeks because the Kurt
Locker is the new show from Gamespot
along with many other new shows that
we're launching and to commemorate this
whole deal we're giving away stuff check
the pin comment below to find out how
you could win a copy of residual 4
remake Jedi Survivor or that thing that
everyone's yapping about the PlayStation
5. that's what it's called uh it's
available to us residents only so terms
and conditions apply with that said make
sure to come back tomorrow because
that'll be the debut episode of no HUD a
show that tells you the best ways the
most exciting cool ways to play the
games that you love alright I'm Kurt
until next time
see ya